[Applause]
this is
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen happen on tv is
when the guys start eating pizza oh my
god god dude
i don't know how you didn't laugh when
the guy goes do you want a slice
i'm good i'm good thank you i'm good
yeah you
have a straight face i would have first
of all number one
i would have absolutely taken a slice
because that pizza had to be so [ __ ]
good
that that guy knew his life was over and
he still took a bite of that pizza i bet
i know where that pizza was from where
is it
i made pizza imagine no it's connecticut
it was planet pizza
wow did you go back were you like i
gotta see what this is like no he's on
a chain in fact my oldest son um
was working on that as one of the camera
operators and uh
he works in the business and um
he wanted to some get some pizza the
predator did jeff sokol
uh girl soon-to-be wife he had a
marriage kind of yeah yeah
so i yell over to my son chase he said
what's what's the best pizza place you
know
right he said well send them to planet
great so we sent them and so the
fairfield police were right there
watching him go in
get the pizza come out so we knew okay
he's eight minutes away and
here comes jeff sokol with the pizza and
he was among
the creepier wow yeah it was
unbelievable like
unfazed by all of that yeah yeah and i'm
sure some of it was
you know what it means i got caught but
i mean still the
balls of this guy to not know who you
are as a pedophile
is disrespectful how [ __ ] arrogant
are you that you're out here trying to
[ __ ] kids and you don't even think about
this guy yeah did he have you a little
convinced that like he might be able to
get off
no not when he took the bite of the
pizza and the cheese was all fallen but
he made sure to scoop up the cheese for
the bite he was just buying time
you think that's what it was he had me
convinced almost like if i was in your
position i'd be like
maybe we got the wrong guy this guy's
eating i can't even eat before i do
stand up this guy's going to prison for
20 years
yeah he was a piece of work you know and
then in his car they found the marriage
contract
that he had and a viagra that you
described quite funny yeah yeah you
didn't say viagra like there's a there's
a pill in the car that you might have to
go to the doctor if you're erect more
than four hours
more than four hours you alluded to a
completely straight are you on are you
on any of the performance enhancement
not at the moment not at the moment
thank god just coffee
yeah yeah we're big supporters of the
peds sure yeah yeah yeah
big big big time on this show that's a
good sponsor to him
it is one of those people we're gonna
take a break for a second
chill yeah um okay so you have all these
like moments with these people
what i was shocked about when i went
back to watch is
one how obedient they are when they see
you
and i'm curious they meaning the like
pedophiles right
so it's like or the predators right so
when they first see you
there's a couple things that look to be
going through their mind one is
oh is this a gang bang or something like
that like they don't immediately go
are you the dad they're like who are you
but they're not terrified and run out
they're kind of calm well they're
stunned some freak out
some obviously especially in the
beginning thought i was either a cop
or the mad father and then as we moved
into the second
third fourth investigation it became
clear that they knew who i was right
from the get-go
immediately and we had a guy for
instance in new jersey
on the shore in manilowkin who said oh
you're chris hansen
and i said how did you know that so i
watch the shows all the time when i miss
him i watch him on the internet
oh god so do you even understand the
trouble that you just walked into
yeah and he was happy to be on the show
do you think some of them want to get
caught
and that's why they're there i think
some are relieved you know we um
revisited a case from ohio a fellow
who's a teacher
uh in his mid-20s who came in and um
you know took a while to get him to
fess up and i think he knew who i was
right from the get-go he had seen some
of the shows
uh and and obviously teachers talk about
this show
in in school and um
he finally breaks and you can see this
moment where he
caves and he said you know i kept
online doing these chats and i knew
they're racy i knew they were sometimes
inappropriate
and i got older and the people with whom
i was chatting
stayed the same or got younger i just
didn't get out
when i should have gotten out and i
think you know
people always say what do these guys
have in common and the answer is white
they don't understand well there's that
that's true no there was there
they don't stand out of a crowd it could
be the guy yeah they look kind of
yeah in the you know dry cleaning line
on a saturday morning
yeah from all walks of life quick funny
anecdote you know you said they're all
white there was an indian guy on there
once and my mom called me and she was
like there was an indian on the
predator you need to be careful online
and i was like what are you
what are you guys doing online what the
[ __ ]
you